Well,
here's the decomposition of the,
of the fundamental archetype.
The dragon of chaos differentiates on
the one hand into the feminine.
That's the unknown,
and the feminine differentiates further
into the negative feminine than the
Positive Feminine.
The negative feminine is the reason for
which haunts.
It's the reason for,
um,
you know,
there's a whole group online called men
going their own way.
M,
g,
T,
O w,
that's a very interesting group to go
study.
There's lots of them.
I don't know how many of them there are,
and most of them are older.
Many of them are men who've been through
a particularly horrifying divorce for
one reason or another,
and there they've had enough of women so
they stay.
Tell that young men that they're
teaching never have a permanent
relationship.
Never share your territory with a woman,
never share your possessions.
Make sure you never lived together and
don't stay with one long enough to enter
a common law relationship because you
will be stripped of everything that you
have.
Well,
that's a hell of a thing to be telling
people,
but what's happened is that the female
has been manifested in their life only
as the negative archetype and they've
got that confused with all women and
that's partly,
you know,
you gotta ask yourself if you know the
mythological stories,
maybe if you made the right sacrifices,
you wouldn't have so much trouble with
women.
It's a,
it's a good question to ask yourself
first,
and I would also say,
you know,
if you're a woman who has trouble with
man or you're a man who has trouble with
women,
it's not the women and it's not the man,
it's you because the women are telling
you what's wrong with you and the men
are telling you what's wrong with you
and if you don't listen then it's you.
It's either you are all men.
Well that's easy.
It's all men.
While that's certainly how it's played
out in the world right now,
it's like,
no,
it's not all men.
You can be by definition,
by definition,
and it's not all women.
That's for sure.
I don't want to have anything to do with
women.
It's like you're a pathetic weasel.
That's the same statement.